>> Jesse: AOC TRYING TO PICK A
FIGHT WITH THE WORLD'S RICHEST
MAN AND DID NOT END WELL,
GETTING ALL CONSPIRATORIAL
DUNKING ON THE NEW OWNER
ELON MUSK.
"LMAO ED A BILLIONAIRE TRYING TO
EARNESTLY SELL PEOPLE ON THE
IDEA THAT FREE SPEECH IS
ACTUALLY $8 A MONTH SUBSCRIPTION
PLAN.
BUT YOU DON'T MESS WITH THE
MASTER TROLL LIKE ELON" HAD HE
FIRED BACK WITH THIS.
"YOUR FEEDBACK IS APPRECIATED,
NOW PAY $8."
SHE IS CONVENIENTLY HAVING
ISSUES WITH HER TWITTER ACCOUNT.
>> SO I PULL UP MY TWITTER APP
AND IT'S LIKE GONE.
WHEN YOU PULL UP YOUR MENTIONS
AND STUFF LIKE THAT, JUST LIKE
LITERALLY LIKE A BLANK SCREEN
TOTALLY GONE.
AND I WAS LIKE THAT'S WEIRD.
SO IT TURNS OUT WE GOT UNDER A
CERTAIN BILLIONAIRE SKIN.
>> Jesse: THAT LOOKS GOOD, I'M
NOT GOING ALIVE.
ALL RIGHT, JESSICA, WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH AOC AND ELON MUSK?
>> Jessica: I DON'T THINK
ANYTHING IS GOING ON, I MAINTAIN
THAT THIS IDEA OF PAYING FOR THE
BLUE CHECK MARK IS NOT GOING TO
WORK OUT THE WAY THAT HE THINKS,
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IT EARLIER
ON NEWSROOM, I'M NOT SURE IF YOU
CAN EXPENSE IT, WHICH WAS YOUR
PLAN.
YOU THINK WE CAN?
>> Greg: YES, YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO PROMOTE "THE FIVE," BUT
IT CAN'T BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE A
BLUE CHECK.
>> Jessica: THERE ARE BIG
ACCOUNTS THAT DON'T HAVE
CHECKMARKS, WHICH I THINK IS
INTERESTING, BUT TWITTER IS JUST
GOING TO FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE,
AND IF THAT'S OKAY WITH PEOPLE,
THEN THAT HAS TO BE OKAY WITH
PEOPLE.
I WENT BACK AND LOOKED AT WHERE
THE BLUE CHECK MARK CAME FROM IN
AND IT WAS A LAWSUIT IN 2009,
THIS GUY TONY LA RUSSA THE
MANAGER OF THE ST. LOUIS
CARDINALS WAS BEING IMPERSONATED
IN THE PERSON WHO IMPERSONATED
HIM WAS SAYING OFFENSIVE THINGS
ABOUT TWO DEAD CARDINALS PLAYERS
AND IT WAS CAUSING A LOT OF
DISTRESS.
SO THEY CREATED THE SYSTEM
BECAUSE IT IS SUPPOSED TO BE A
VERIFICATION OF REAL PEOPLE.
AND IF IT IS JUST $8 A MONTH, WE
MIGHT SIT HERE AND SAY I DON'T
WANT TO DO THAT, BUT A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT WHO THEY ARE
GOING TO BE SAYING THAT THEY ARE
ARE GOING TO PAY FOR IT AND IT'S
GOING TO TURN TWITTER AND DO
SOMETHING THAT IT WAS NOT
INTENDED TO BEAT.
AND IF PEOPLE ARE COOL WITH
THAT, THAT'S FINE, BUT THEY WILL
HAVE TO FIND ANOTHER PLACE TO GO
IF YOU ACTUALLY WANT IT TO BE A
CURATED NEWS FOR TRUSTED
INDIVIDUALS.
>> Jesse: SHE IS COMPLAINING
THAT PEOPLE CAN'T SEE WHAT SHE
IS SAYING ABOUT HER, BUT HOW
DOES "THE NEW YORK POST" FEEL,
THEY GOT COMPLETELY SHUT DOWN?
SPEWING WAS ON THAT RIGHT BEFORE
THE ELECTION WHEN THEY DIDN'T
WANT US TO HEAR ABOUT HUNTER
BIDEN AND THEY DIDN'T WANT US TO
KNOW THAT HUNTER BIDEN WAS
REALLY A DIRTBAG WHOSE HOUSE
SHOULD'VE BEEN RAIDED BY THE
FBI?
BUT YOU KNOW, THE THING ABOUT
WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE
AOC, TALKING ABOUT LMAO IS THAT
SHE IS ALWAYS ANGRY, AND SHE IS
ALWAYS FIGHTING, BUT THERE IS
NO --
SHE DOES NOT PRODUCE ANYTHING.
SHE DOES NOT DO ANYTHING THAT
BENEFITS ANYBODY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT HER
WHOLE FOCUS IS.
>> Jesse: SHE LOST NEW YORK
MILLIONS OF JOBS.
>> Greg: LITERALLY SELLS
SWEATSHIRTS FOR $60, THIS FEELS
LIKE THE BEGINNING OF AN AURA
FROM ROMANTIC COMEDY.
BILLIONAIRE LIBERTARIAN BIAS
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM WHERE A
YOUNG DEFIANT FEMALE PROGRESSIVE
SPENDS ALL OF HER TIME!
SHE FINDS HIM REPUGNANT, YET SHE
OWNS ONE OF HIS CARS.
HE FINDS HER IDEA IS SILLY, BUT
IS CAPTIVATED BY HER CHARM.
GEORGE CLOONEY, J.LO, THEY MIGHT
HAVE AGED OUT OF THIS, BUT DID I
JUST WRITE A MOVIE?
>> Dana: COULD BE
SELENA GOMEZ.
>> Greg: AND HARRY STYLES, BUT
HE CAN'T WEAR A DRESS IN THIS, I
AM AGAINST THAT.
>> Dana: IT CROSSED MY MIND,
IT DID CROSS MY MIND.
TWITTER IS NOT A PUBLIC SERVICE.
IT IS A COMPANY.
THIS IS HOW COMPANIES WORK.
YOU HAVE AN ECONOMIC SUPERIORITY
SOMEWHERE IN BOSTON, YOU SHOULD
KNOW THAT.
BUT HE REALLY SEE BOTH SIDES OF
THE $8 ISSUE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW IT WILL COME
DOWN ON IT IN THE END.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN'T BOTH SIDES
THIS ONE, DANA.
>> Dana: YOU DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE A FINAL >> Greg: THEIR
CHECKMARKS ON BOTH SIDES.
A >> Dana: YOU DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE A FINAL DECISION UNTIL THE
$8 IS DUE.
IT WAS LIKE TWITTER DRIVES ME
NUTS, MAYBE THIS IS THE BEST WAY
TO GET OFF, BUT I DON'T WANT
PEOPLE IMPERSONATING ME
ON TWITTER.
AND I DON'T LIKE ALL OF THESE
ADS I'M SEEING.
>> Greg: JESSICA SAYS THE
ORIGINAL INTENT WAS FOR THE
IMPERSONATIONS, BUT WHY WE DON'T
LIKE IT IS BECAUSE NOW IT IS
STATUS, IT'S LIKE I HAVE A BLUE
CHECK, THAT'S THE THING THAT
MAKES IT NAUSEATING PARTS OF
PAYING FOR THAT MEANS THAT YOU
ARE PAYING FOR THE STATUS.
>> Jessica: A LOT OF THESE
BLUE CHECKS HAVE ASKED FOR IT,
THERE ACCOUNTS WHERE YOU CLICK
ON IT AND IT'S LIKE 982
FOLLOWERS.
SAYING THAT THE SYSTEM IS
OBVIOUSLY YOU COULD HAVE GAINED
IT BEFORE, BUT THIS FEELS LIKE A
CORRUPTION OF IT.
>> Greg: WHAT IF YOU TAKE UP